most video game difficulties are basic
and restrictive easy medium hard
shouldn't games offer more flexibility
for players well it's not as new of a
concept as you might think in fact the
idea has been around since 1994.
[Music]
almost 30 years ago the original System
Shock offered a custom difficulty that
lets players tweak individual aspects of
the game to create their ideal gameplay
experience and now the new remake offers
the same thing and I'm going to use it
as an example of how games can do more
with difficulty and just highlight how
cool System Shock is
but what are the flaws of the standard
way most games handle difficulty you get
a series of presets easy medium often
the default hard and maybe a fourth
option like hardcore or legendary
typically game center around combat
adjusting damage outputs and the health
of both the player and enemies sometimes
the difficulty setting offers more
changes like how Resident Evils switches
up enemy locations or makes puzzles
harder some offer even more unique
challenges like being able to save only
a certain number of times or permadeath
the problem is most of the time these
are binary options where the challenge
is ramped up in all aspects of the game
instead of individually maybe you prefer
harder puzzles but find the increase in
combat difficulty to be too much most
games say sorry it all comes as a
package deal this is where a system shot
comes in the game instead breaks things
into four different categories three of
them are specific to different aspects
of the game and the fourth has wider
reaching changes to the pacing each has
three different levels of challenge to
choose from Level 2 is the default
experience with level 1 being easier and
of course level 3 being harder
combat is well all about combat it does
the usual thing we talk about most games
doing adjusting health and damage so
level 1 enemies have less health and
take fewer bullets to drop meanwhile
level 3 enemies are a lot beefier and
hit you for more substantial damage but
that's not the only change the quantity
of foes aboard Citadel station alter as
well so on Level 3 you might get an
extra cyborg or two in a room System
Shock is a game all about backtracking
and revisiting old locations and to keep
you on your toes the game will
repopulate older areas with new foes the
degree of which this will happen is
dictated by your combat level finally
the awareness of the enemy AI is tweaked
on Level 3 enemies around the corner
would be alerted to my presence and Rush
after me meanwhile on level 1 it is
possible to walk past an inattentive
mutant without them noticing it
the Cyber setting meanwhile is much more
specific you'll find terminals
throughout Citadel station that allow
you to jack into a 90s interpretation of
cyberspace straight out of the lawnmower
man you'll navigate these small levels
deactivating barriers and shooting down
cyber security while some of these are
optional they are typically worth doing
to help unlock a door and there are
times where you have to use them
personally I enjoyed the change of Paces
can bring but they can get quite
difficult in spots and dying means
getting booted back to the real world
and needing to start all over again
which can get annoying so if you find
these mini games tedious or just not
very fun you can reduce the challenge by
setting cyber to level 1. enemies are
still present but they die much quicker
and cyberspace as a whole is less
frustrating of course you can take it in
the opposite direction instead and up
the challenge to level three now if you
die in cyberspace you die for real and
need to load a save
my vision is it is fast
next is the puzzle difficulty which is
by far the most straightforward the game
is full of these neat little junction
box puzzles level one makes the puzzles
easier and level 3 makes them a lot
harder as someone who loves a good brain
teaser I really enjoy the added
challenge of these level 3 puzzles but
obviously that isn't going to be for
everyone
[Music]
the final setting is called Mission and
this is by far the most interesting as
it can change a number of different
factors by default System Shock is a
game that doesn't hold your hand after
the game's prologue you wake up on
Citadel station and are left to figure
out the rest there's no Quest log no
arrow pointing where to go next or even
an objective given to you outside of
stopping showdan it's up to you to put
the pieces together and figure out what
to do next using context clues from
audio and text logs
no updates from him yet
we're safe here
this is incredibly faithful to the
original 1994 game and feels unique and
rewarding in 2023 where games just can't
help themselves but tell you exactly
what to do next however the lack of any
direction can be off-putting which is
why if you set mission to level 1 the
game will provide waypoints to assist
players on top of that several important
key codes that are otherwise randomized
will instead be fixed and you can no
longer drop Mission critical items
setting mission to level 3 meanwhile
brings back a fun bonus challenge the
original game also had a time limit you
now have five hours to stop Shodan and
beat the game of course this is
something I would not recommend for a
first time playthrough to beat the game
in 5 hours requires pretty intimate
knowledge of Citadel station and knowing
pretty much exactly what to do but it is
a wonderful Challenge on repeat
playthroughs typically on other games a
hardcore challenge like a time limit
would also be locked on a higher
difficulty that also UPS the a combat
challenge the puzzles Etc but in System
Shock you're free to try this out but
also keep everything else at level one
if that's what you prefer the choice is
up to you and that is what's so great
about custom difficulties hate the
cyberspace challenges set that to level
one so you can get in and out of them
quickly love doing The Little Door
hacking puzzles try them on Level 3 for
a fun challenge does your spatial
awareness suck and you need a clear path
forward set mission to level one the
downside to the system and really just
difficulty systems in general is that
you won't know what's best for you until
you play the game for yourself my first
time through I played the game on the
default for everything just to get a
baseline experience then I redid the
first area of the game on level 1 for
everything and then on Level 3 for
everything just to get a sense of what
they were like after all this testing my
ideal experience for this game would be
combat level 2 mission level 2 cyber
level 1 and Puzzle level 3. but that's
just me hopefully this video has given
you at least some basic knowledge to
find your perfect difficulty if you end
up playing System Shock for yourself
which you should it is absolutely
brilliant a real forward-thinking game
that pioneered lots of systems that we
now take for granted today and to be
frank didn't get enough credit for so
perhaps off to night dive Studios for
keeping system shocks forward-thinking
difficulty system of course there have
been plenty of games over the years that
have experimented with custom
difficulties like Dishonored 2 shadow of
the Tomb Raider or even recent remakes
like The Last of Us Part 1. so let me
know in the comments any games you think
handle custom difficulty well as well as
if you are planning on playing The
System Shock remake
thank you